hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the escapists as you
can see it's the middle of day 7 and
I've been playing along trying to
understand the game and I actually
understand that the escape part of it
isn't like the end-all goal like getting
to the escape part takes a lot of time
and planning and I was expecting to be
able to do it in like a day and that's
where I kind of went wrong but the
actuality of the game is that you kind
of live in the world and you got to
interact with the other people and you
got to learn like the people and what
they want you got to do them favors in
you how to get stuff and yet eventually
learn to craft things and you got to go
forward and forward and forward and you
also have to build up your statuses at
the same time because if you're ever
gonna want to escape you're gonna need
to have enough stats to do that so it's
like a day-by-day thing I've slowly been
going by I got put in solitary
confinement so I haven't been going all
the days but I was trying to stay out in
the middle of the night but so I was
originally going to keep playing until I
figure out a way to actually escape but
like this is the game like this is the
real game this is how you play it you
you work towards that eventual goal and
it may happen quickly or not depending
on your luck of finding items I still
don't know anymore crafting items in
just the comb blade and I even lost my
comb blade the only thing I'm wheeling
is a plastic knife but right now I'm
just trying to build up my strength so
that I can actually do all the
beat-em-up favors and I did learn that
like when I get favors hand um I need a
comb Shiv and I need to distract in the
shower block so pretty soon it's gonna
be the shower block period as you guys
will be able to see and I'm gonna do a
distract em I'm gonna get a little money
and then I'm gonna get the last tip from
the pay phone to see if that actually
does have anything that's good for me
now my strength isn't incredible it's
only at 40 but it's better than what I
started with Young Buck was pretty wimpy
when he walked into this place and he's
gonna walk out a man it's probably man
when I walked in but you know what I
mean couldn't Photoshop this oh I tried
I probably could try I'm very good
you're talking a lot over there who is
that anyway that's do gir ah do gir you
can brag all you want you can even throw
guards working them that we know who do
gir we know about your abs okay um I'm
looking for a comb Shiv comb ship is
different than a comb blade oh say yes
now okay the distraction ones are easy
cuz all I have to do is hit a guard and
then run away really quickly and
eventually you can get away from guards
and they actually stop following you
after a while okay hey I didn't do
nothing okay so what I got to do here is
I gotta distract officer Wade Dany favor
complete I take one little Bop on the
head and I just get away and what I can
do is I can go into the infirmary we're
gonna either rest in the bed to build up
my health or I can just go into that
closet there if he's actually coming
close but either way you kind of just
forgets about it
Wade waits forgetful sometimes you know
he's just like his mind isn't a hundred
percent there all the time so I just
kind of wand there's a bit out meanders
if you know what I mean but either way
so that's all there is to it but now I
have enough money so that I can buy the
other tip and I actually don't know yet
how to trade money with other inmates
cuz I mean it's totally possible I think
that what if you could make a mold of an
unconscious guards key and return the
key back to him before he even knew is
missing
well that's a thing that I didn't think
of before but I haven't even been able
to knock out a guard but if I do have
money okay here's the thing if I do have
money I do believe that these like
things above their head means that like
I can trade with them at some point and
I can sell or buy from them but and I
need to make sure that was I supposed to
this isn't breakfast okay so my lucky
poster has found its way to pilfering
palm of Danny get it back and I'll see
you right okay
I need a comb shift god everyone needs a
comb Shiv alright I need a I need to
crap out some of these he needs to comb
chips he needs three comb chips God he
really wants a comb shift forget you
you're a man marish does he forget he
already asked me to do that that would
have been a triple payout though you go
bum bums bents mitching me out to the
gods perhaps a beating will shut his
mouth yeah I'm getting swung gut so
eventually I'm gonna be able to do that
okay so I okay he's got a pillow ah here
we go that's right right-click on him
louboutin who a magazine okay so this is
all new self that I'm discovering how do
you have money I have money and I have
the ability to do it but I need
more money Doogie is unconscious next
breakfast okay so that's two things for
breakfast tomorrow that's two things for
Eagle bum bum I bet I get I'm hoping I
get double paid for that smells rank too
bad flying my mash take it up with you
I'm a man shrew so if he's still in [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] septic Dugan all right fine
you used to be a cab driver fine for you
I don't think that helps in any way now
okay so I'm gonna need is I'm actually
gonna need to get a job because a job
actually is a good way to get money if
I'm not able to do these things I am
able to get jabs damn it I don't have
enough intellect to do that
I lost my laundry job and the laundry
job was actually nice didn't pay all
that well but at least it did something
okay
so for the rest of the evening I'm gonna
work out to try to build up my strength
actually I'm gonna work on my
intelligence I can do that a little more
because eventually if I can get a job
that might be good for me now I'm gonna
work out because working out gives me
more strength and more life which but
preferably means I'm going to be able to
survive more hits if I ever need to beat
someone up and take it stuff this is
exactly what I am to do sometime down
the road now I mentioned before this
looks like earthbound but what it
actually looks like is the era of these
sprites where this was how characters
were represented earthbound did look a
lot like this but so did a lot of other
games like the Final Fantasy games early
on and stuff like that not say still
doesn't remind me earthbound it still
does definitely does goddamnit it does
I'm a second I should play I haven't
played through it in a long time it's
one of my favorite games of all times
and if you haven't checked out
earthbound have it do it do it do it now
okay officer leave ox dog died what have
you got for me not a rain screw you
who are you and your face also I got a
lot of stuff I have a whole bunch of
stuff and I've tried various
combinations to craft but crafting isn't
as a parent as I thought I got like a
broom I thought maybe I could put nails
on the end of it cream like a weapon no
that didn't work
I don't know there's so many different
things to do in the game that I just
don't understand
yo hey burb burb you carry on I'll just
get naked for like two seconds oh yeah
la la la la la la I mean a lot of this
game is just interacting with the other
people see them on I want to dump with
you sink was it you was he using [ __ ]
aluminum on alright no one's got time to
chat apparently what I guess I'm not
bored enough whatever alright
I'd be honored to end you Wow thanks
Wade
uh okay he's got razor blades bar
chocolate like the road might be good
was Danny got I need to find crafting
note I would love it but I don't have
the money I need to distract anyone for
the evening
no just breakfast but I do have to beat
up ego bum bum and I can't do it right
now but I will
maybe tomorrow you go bum bum and young
buck you go bum bum and young buck
although damn it I want that I want that
align and then get over the road call I
need to get to bed aim to please sure
you do someone devout all the custom
group have it not the custard creams
some interesting developments someone
flood the toilets that is very
interesting in what way punished with
love I'm sure you do heart too bad too
bad all right so that's another night
down but I'm gonna keep rolling with
this episode because I want to show you
guys just a bit more I mean this is the
game it's a game and it's actually a fun
game by which I could escape god I wish
I was smarter and stronger Danny guy
think it's still that crafting note okay
so
morning breakfast so I need a wait till
breakfast to create a distraction for
ego bomb bomb lighter roll duct tape
timber
I mean I'm able to get a lot of stuff
just by you know sneaking into other
people's desks and grabbing them but I
have not been able to get all that I
need not the higher end stuff like only
random miscellaneous items but anyway
we're upgrading our cable TV packages
Romans yay that reminds me the prisoner
is always right thank you I know it
makes me feel so good that Yowie and
someone is still flying to us okay
that's good good your needs are of our
ammo turn okay grandma please
time for a distraction at breakfast you
go bomb Bob is gonna pay me look to
money hopefully there's no guards here
yet those are gonna be a distraction if
there's no guards alrighty then
I guess okay here we go okay so as soon
as that guy comes in combat mode popped
on that Oh nah shift young buck I don't
know what that means
but I'm just gonna go away gone they
don't follow they're very far like I've
found they don't do much at all okay so
I've got money now so I'm gonna keep
money to buy stuff with from other guys
I'm just gonna keep working out in the
meantime
hey free Pierre let me actually go try
to find hey Ferb what do you want burb
burb burb burb burb burb home ship got I
don't have a comb ship kiss off sell me
crap ah you got nothing I want uh
burb okay bye I stopped visiting with
your that no Bob it's so sad Bob
actually is buried you you go Bob up
have you got for me no you go Bob Bob go
back damn it you don't have anything I
need I need a goddamn screwdriver
something important something of value
oh damn it these people don't have
anything to sell sorry bro not a good
time what is a good time for you what is
a good time for any of you you all have
to stay here while you still don't have
anything did God ah you know the same
people that made this game or at least
team17 I don't if they made it or if
they were in charge of it or something
like that they made worms they made
worms revolution that's pretty cool well
that's interesting for officer Gary but
I need to find ah where was all the cool
stuff from before I guess I can just
search the desks again hmm
nope nothing got a cookie though so
that's nice silk handkerchief that
sounds important I don't know if it is
but maybe it is talcum powder always
good I guess the comb chip someone
needed a comb chip I'll give up my code
for that comb Shiv thank you very much
anything else I need it's very rarely
did I actually find something like that
that I need lighter okay that sounds
like it might be important I think I
have a tube of superglue back in my
place
okay lighter so that was actually an
expensive item on someone's list
launched I need to do anything for lunch
nobody I have a comb ship for yarman
American manners I need to give that as
soon as I can
Bharat Shaklee goody gumdrops bird
Jackie I'm on the way need to find your
room in there manures Yarmuth smear do
yaar McMurdo hey Yama Schmo do I uh I
had got something for you McCall ship
take it with love
okay so Japs ethnic dub dub file I might
be good for something else I could like
file down uh could file down like
something to get that I guess I'll take
that that sounds like it's a good uh and
his crew on the outside or as my family
seen them laid to the floor jab set to
dig well I'll share all punched
jacksepticeye don't care
see I'm the lookout for comb ship and
everyone's a gum yeah I don't have
enough ah Roo what do you got for me
crowbar yeah I don't have enough money
for that I would love to have a poster
or a magazine that's that post is a
magazine
ah wish I could just sell people this
stuff I don't know what would happen if
I just gave someone something like is
there any is that giving them money or
is that asking for what whatever
whatever
screw you that was a silk handkerchief
gift you are a son of a [ __ ] you know
ok beat up [ __ ] scepter dig beat up
madman movement him or beat up ego bum
bum God all these favors
stop being douches ok no no no no no no
come here home shift guy everyone wants
come shift
ok there's lots over
stealing from you guys mine trouble I
can dig stop get back stuff I can dig
stuff oh my god does that mean I can dig
stuff big stuff can dig step I can dig
stuff oh I can dig stuff I can dig fine
get outside at night I can dig stuff up
oh there's gonna be a good thing I think
anyway I hope that's gonna be a good
thing I'm pretty sure that means that
I'm gonna actually be able to do
something get out of here I'd love to be
able to do that okay so that bodes well
for me I'm gonna end this episode here
and continue this in him one more I
think that'll be the end of the ones
that I need to record for packs but I'm
gonna get out of here we're gonna have
the very easy prison ie the way
I'm learning I'm learning guys I'm
learning I might be wrong here but I'm
still learning so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
is what it is a game about trying to get
home or my damn bastard kids Jenna okay
no you always start out with a pack
adventure book I love it I was spitting
everywhere
oh that